sap e sto per avere un bambino
tagli a riccardo sì non lo sapevo è
visto allora facile idiota non fa niente
ci penso io a compensare bene dei
ragazzi come deve solo venire sono fatti
james aprile che mi accompagna in questa
avventura incredibile che si chiama
famiglia io sono contento che sto per
diventare papà
io ormai fatta stanza femmina quindi ho
fatto tutto forza di vendere tutto un
camion e infine non sappiamo come
chiamarlo a chiamarla però il problema è
che se esce maschio abbiamo buttato dei
soldi quindi un mio dio sopra nella
buttare detto allora vanno risparmiati i
soldi perché possiamo buttar lì così è
joe 2 milioni di sim o leon che vanno
via che è un piacere
allora erano ragazzi ragazzi che il mio
cane eros tutti in rosso sono ho bisogno
di divertimento ragazza è vero ho
bisogno di divertirci e ti pare in un
gioco a videogiochi da una settimana
manco stessi avendo un figlio console di
vino già sono l'inter con l'accoglimento
anche la cosa spetta
quanto costa che te frega te la regalo
io stai zitto
mi ha fatto una casa ragazzi solo per la
console arcade veniva lo sai che dirti
brogli dei lo so che vivrai lì dentro
vai affari tuoi doveri di uomo gioca ad
un gioco arcade
quelli sono i doveri di nuovo con mia
moglie dai con selena giochiamo noi
giocatori che bambino a metà slug donna
vieni amore lasciarvela cercare ok anche
arrivare tutto anche il cane a giocare
tutti e tre i giochiamo sta giocando da
slogan che lì si sta divertendo che
stavano famiglia angurie paragone ci
stiamo divertendo tutti e tre sono tutti
e tre in rosso dopo arriva il telefono
azzurro ci prende tutti e tre perché
avete fame
i giochi sono più importanti giocate e
divertitevi non ascoltatelo il mio cane
vacca deve fare la cacca non farla qua
perché sennò poi c'è una puzza
incredibile mia moglie è rimasto a
giocare io l'ho lasciata rivisto lo
distratta facendo sta andando a letto ma
non andare a letto da mangiare ma muore
di sonno muore di sonno vuole fame morti
non ti sei ancora verso abbastanza
marconi verdi e di due videogiochi io
faccio tre cose insieme mangio gioco e
dormo insieme ok mentre gioco capito si
fa così lui non sa farlo perché non sa
farlo come so fare io metto un abito che
sei chirchio masto tavolino lo vogliamo
mettere un po più carino non ammette sto
schifo con le lezioni della nomina
ascoltami io lavoro per neanche fatto da
mangiare se lo si è fatto solo portavano
dietro mentre i vegani vegetariano era
perché lega non so cucinare hildegard
miracolo che sono mimmo riva lei e il
bambino sia cucinavo io mi arresta per
finire in piscina attenzione allora
sabrina guarda guarda guarda quanto
verde c'è guarda guarda quanto bagnarsi
malese gaga piscia mangiava c'è una
prateria ma chi è che c'è una parte di
sé un cane così fai le cose ma dai ma
scusami ma chi ha il pane non al cane
rialzo o mio dio fermati ferma tutto
pausa pausa vanta rispetto aspetto sta
lavando i piatti il secondo ha iniziato
il travaglio sai cosa vuol dire vuol
dire che mi sto pagando addosso sì
quello sempre lardani raiale ott io dico
che si faccia vuol dire che è arrivato
il momento di partorire quindi quindi
parole ai previsto di lei ma è un
visitor so bambino guardo a perdere fino
a svelare lo faccio per le velate vai
partecipa spedale partecipate chip a
colori con lorenzo lumiere cane perché
voglio dire
al cane non puoi non si partorisce devi
guardare un punto fisso non ha
sinceramente riguarda un punto fisso
signora di un punto fisso e con te così
sofia candelina poi certamente ospedale
di locri
allora signora mia moglie a un visitor
nella francia faccia qualcosa
in accettazione ha raccolto solo il
fabbricato accettazione ha speso 5 euro
intanto che cosa non lo so ho buttato
dei soldi per terra accettazione salve
fatti registrare download capitolo de le
monde
salve sto per esplodere mi date una mano
si prenda il biglietto si siedano a
partorire scusami questo qua è una
navicella spaziale
facciamo il tirocinio sul mio partner
sta andando bene molto bene
guarda come va bene va bene tesoro stai
tranquilla se in buone mani
mia moglie sta portando sono fermati sta
giocando del gioco porta è nato un
maschietto come un facciamo dei soldi
marta carta ormai eletto lady oscar hai
capito adesso lei è per forza una
ragazza non è una ragazza ma che
giovanni ma che nicole ma che alberto
alberta non fece male tua figlia il tuo
figlio dell alberta ma no dai è fatto
abbastanza per ragazza ho capito che è
fatto abbastanza per donne li vendiamo
la parete le mettiamo un altra
genuflessa sino genuflessa ostuni cui
gomez a questa stagione il gioco delle
cicogne e ma io sono felice
eccolo
ecco la cia tesoro amore della mia vita
vieni qua che ti do i bacini guarda che
molla e venderà casa e se il bambino a
casa
amore casette perché ora magicamente re
tuo figlio nella cui genuflessa una
veramente l'ha chiamato me ne vado dai
genuflesso sony gomez la mia figlia la
mia bambina
l'amore immagino che tu avrai voi
volevate essere chiamati genuflessa
avrai un sacco di giocattoli belli e di
barbie perché il tuo papà rino che ha
fatto la stanza per una vera principessa
è una ragazza a richiamarlo ma la
svendiamo la smettiamo allora la prima
serie che faccio idee rupaul su netflix
io non sto facendo niente la mia vita le
cose è visto giocare guarda il sorriso
della serie sta andando
bene io non resta molta fame se non sarà
nutrito presto verrà portato via
13 nutrice nuovo no la donna della donna
eravamo una volta che ho scelto io è la
donna doveva è nutri nutri che cuoce al
telefono azzurro three fai dei versetti
nutri nutri allatta allatta il sinn
esatto amore allatta la misura tutto
bene
mio figlio e cioè io mi sto toccando una
che sta migliorando la pace l'utilità di
lorenzo in questa serie a grattarsi la
pancia perché se è vero potere di resti
così è nato un maschio l'ho chiamato
genuflessa far si è fatto la cacca ad
hoc magari la puliamo adesso lo portiamo
il canile e lo scambiano per un suo
simile mutri con il biberon
no no evil non vedi che emana autore dal
sedere di ricambiare i bar mano e poi
mangia fa le puzze e normale allora
spesso allora cambia panini ma lele
cambia il pannolino dove cambia il
pannolino sporco perché devo fare io ste
cose che schifo da l'omesso il costo per
posto i padri che centra tutto che la
cacca perché sono il padre ma scusa mi
guarda mi guarda come comuni sono adatto
per questo mestiere effettiva farina
faccia poi dei versetti facciamolo
passare di età altre scelte peccato
perché piccoli che siano troppo tenero
tipo di peluche ma non puoi interna
quanta voglia di farlo vediamo come bene
la nostra genuflessa sta crescendo
io non lo so non sta bene a genova ma
savaia d'asino aiutati aiutati fat
evitare dal papa le ha donato infatti
non esita a fare il cretino però che
voglia che ciò che tenero tesoro è una
patatina è una ragazza smettila
guarda la sentirono librino dirgli di
non è una e una ragazza non è che gli
faccio notare un e dell'arredamento si
adatta a lui lei a cambiare il colore
guarda che sono soldi sono soldi non li
spendiamo i soldi così c'è una scusa ma
anche valore diamo la moneta è furente
che furente leggi furia per la fase i 36
avanzato deriva perché io dove sono
finito dai da mangiare come si fa come
si fa padre vito tuo figlio genitori
vediamo torna indietro cure via beh dai
dati mia figlia ha mai fatto nella
finanza solo porta via la pizza è nato
ieri con la pista e mio figlio è il mio
figlio è proprio un amore di bebè voglio
vedere come mi chiedo da mangiare mia
moglie a spasso col cane elemento che
taglia il giardino di casa e quindi cosa
sta facendo quello che sono io dove sono
io ma basta non fare più niente
la dei lori buona serie diverto sto
facendo
mangio ibisco io oggi questo bello
aiutarti a far da genitore dai la beva
area le basi controlla il the day prende
in braccio dai l'avevano credenti
andiamo adesso si dà la birra dominio ok
niente abbiamo perso il supporto ragazzi
apro io gli darei da bere la birra
insieme non si beve latte latte prendi
latte bravo ed è aderente a posto a
posto signori spero che questo vi sia
piaciuto di sapere se mi sta piacendo
the sims questa la mia famiglia
ringrazio sabrina per aver partecipato a
dei grandi problemi la sua famiglia ma è
comunque noi una famiglia se video e che
ci fosse un momento mi piace anche la
dice già cominciato a litigare si chiede
perciò lo possiamo o attività familiare
che dir si voglia insomma
mondo figlio no però stanno mangiando
dei piselli ma è bene ragazzi
[Musica]